تبعنا هذا الجزء من كلمه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين امين هذه الكلمه طال
انتظار هواء كانوا ينتظر ان تحمل موقف
الكرملين من هذه الازمه بين بريجوجين
ووزاره الدفاع وتحدثت بوتين عن خيانه
وعقاب على تمرد المسلح ما ابرز ما جاء في
هذه الكلمات
[تصفيق]
سهام ربما كما انتظر كثيرون هنا في روسيا
رئيس بوتين من خلال هذه الكلمه وهي في
الحقيقه اول حديث
وتصريح مباشر عمان جرى او يجري حتى الان
بدا واضحا ان بوتين يقف الى صف وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه والجيش الروسي وحمل
تبعات ما يجري الان تحدث عن او تحدث
بمفردات من قبيل توجيه طعنه في الظهر ايضا
وجود خيانه
ومغامره عسكريه مسلحه دعا كل من ان جر
بحسب قوله الى هذه المغامره المسلحه الى
العوده الى رشدهم والتحلي بالحكمه والعقل
وتوعد في المقابل بان بانه هو رئيس للدوله
ملزم باتخاذ تدابير وصفها بالصارمه من اجل
حمايه المجتمع الروسي من اجل حمايه
التاريخ روسيا وهنا بوتين
التذكير باحداث عام
1917 في اشاره طبعا واضحه الى الثوره
وما تبعها من احداث وحرب اهليه في روسيا
قال بان البلاد لا يجب ان تعود الى تلك
الحقبه لكنه لم يتحدث بوتين هنا وهو هذا
هو اللافت سهام عن اجراءات محدده بالاسم
عما ستتخذه وزاره الدفاع عن ما سيتخذها
الكريميلين من اجراءات من اجل
اعاده لنقل الاوضاع الى طبيعتها لكن يبدو
من خلال نظرته من خلال المفردات
والمصطلحات التي استخدمها بان
الكرملين يرفض رفضا قاطعا ما يجري الان
هذا يرفض هذا التحرك العسكري
ليفغيني
وقال بان ضد روسيا او روسيا تخوض صراعا
صعبا للغايه وبان كل الامكانيات العسكريه
للغرب موجهه في الوقت الراهن ضد روسيا
وبالتالي بحسب قوله لا توجد خيارات امام
روسيا الا التعامل بصرامه مع ما يجري الان
هو لربما حينما يمنح بوتين لربما فتره او
مهله لتلك القوات القوات فاجنر من اجل
العوده الى رشدها كما قال او التحلي
بالعقل يبدو
ان هناك اشارات لربما الى امكانيه اجراء
حوار او مفاوضات بين الجيش الروسي
وفاكنر لكن يبدو ان الامور تتجه الى اتخاذ
تدابير كما قال بوتين صارمه من اجل عدم
السماح
بحدوث خيانه حدوث تمرد مسلح في البلاد هذه
طبعا هي الملامح العامه لهذه الكلمه التي
طال انتظارها لكن بدا واضحا ان بوتين غير
راضي يرفض رفضا قاطعا وهدما كان منتظرا
بطبيعه الحال لما يجري الان في الجنوب
ربما قد تتبع هذه الكلمه
تصريحات جديده لمؤسس شركه فاجنر يفغيني
المتواجد كما نعلم حاليا في مدينه
روسطوف والذي كان قد منح ايضا مهله لنا
وزير الدفاع الروسي ونائب قائد القوات
القوات العمليه العسكريه الخاصه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا اما بتسليم قائد الاركان
ووزير الدفاع او ان قواته ستتوجه الى
العاصمه الروسيه طبعا بعد الحديث عن طبعا
نقلا عن الذي قال بان قواته تسيطر على
كافه المنشات العسكريه في مقاطعه روستوف
بعد ذلك كانت هناك مصادر امنيه روسيه
تحدثت عن ان قوات تسيطر ايضا على كل
المنشات العسكريه في مدينه فارونج
المجاوره لرستو والتي تقع عن بعد او على
بعد 500 كلم الى جنوب وهي تقع في المنتصف
منتصف الطريق طريق ام اربعه رابط بين
روسيا عفوا بين موسكو روستوف هناك حاله
فرض حاله الطوارئ فرض حاله
نفحت الارهاب في عدد من المقاطعات الروسيه
بما فيها طبعا العاصمه موسكو مقاطعه موسكو
فارونج
وغيرها من
المقاطعات الحدوديه او القريبه مع
اوكرانيا للتعامل مع كما قال طبعا لجنه
مكافحه الارهاب الروسيه التعامل مع
امكانيه حدوث اعمال ارهابيه او هجمات
ارهابيه مع الغاء كل الفعاليات الجماهيريه
ووضع كل الاجهزه الامنيه في روسيا على
اهبه الاستعداد للتعامل مع هذا الوضع في
وقت كما ذكرت سهام قبل قليل في خبر على ان
قوات الامن طوقت مبنى مقر شركه فاقنر
العسكريه في مدينه
توجه نحو اقتحام هذا المبنى او المقر
الرئيسي في انتظار طبعا ردت فعل الان
بريغوجين على تصريحات ب وتين على هذه
اللغه الصارمه على هذا الوعيد لنقل اذا ما
لم تتراجع قوات فاجنر في شخص
باعتباره قائد هذه الشركه العسكريه
الروسيه فان السلطات الروسيه بكافه
اجهزتها ستتخذ اجراءات صارمه لاعاده
الامور الى طبيعتها